manifesting is astrology for straight
guys
do you do you manifest let's just give
your answer one two three
[Music]
it's finally here a day that I have been
waiting for since this game premiered we
have a very very special guest
before we get to that though you're a
special guest and you sometimes have
special guests over to your home that's
why you got to get the Yes or No Game No
real get no what do you mean no
it's Michael malice by the way yeah
Michael malice is our guest the author
of the white pill the game that you
gotta buy despite what Michael tells you
is the yes or no game you can have it
you invite your friends over uh you can
play it you can drink you don't need to
drink have a couple coca-colas do
whatever you want to do answer all the
pressing questions questions about
feminism questions about seed oils
questions about the New World Order
questions about all of it figure out how
well you know your friends and family
the first round sold out immediately the
second round is going to sell out
immediately so pre-order it right now
dailywire.com shop while you're there
pick up Mr malice's new book the white
belt Michael
I am ecstatic to be here now are you
familiar with the rules I am familiar
with the rules I always let the ladies
go first but now if it's just us fellas
I'll go first
wow producers coming you know I haven't
seen any of these questions okay
producers coming out strong
true Anarchy has never been tried
true Anarchy has never been tried so so
if I say no then it's like no it has
been tried
correct okay okay
uh and for you you would also say that
Mr malice
you have to drink
well I have to drink wine you have to
drink yours yeah you have to drink your
delicious but you got it right
all right but I got it right for you
okay so you say it has been where has
Anarchy been tried this is an anarchist
relationship anarchism is not a location
it's a relationship it just means one
person is not in a position to impose
their Authority on another so anarchism
is the basis of all peace relationships
in any society but we but within this
Society right now there are people who
can impose their will on us sure within
this building I'm just speaking about
our relationship so that is true
anarchism but but doesn't anarchism
require more of a political structure by
which I mean it doesn't exist in a
vacuum so you might say that our
relationship does not involve any kind
of coercion right but our relationship
exists within the context of Nashville
Tennessee the United States the world
the world sure which is not anarchistic
which is quite not Anarchist sure but at
a certain point I think that that's kind
of this whole thing about like if you
have this gas stove you're causing
global warming at a certain point the
relationship is uh distinct enough to be
mean English I mean I guess the world
courts in a sense have the power to have
authority over us but in what practice
not in this country well I do I don't
know yet at least yeah
um so I think it just depends on what
your way is of looking at it and from my
perspective I would say uh not only this
anarchism been tried it is the basis of
any successful interaction in any uh
Society do you think it's been tried in
a political context like sometimes oh
yes went to Iceland like Viking age
Iceland the Irish for for centuries um
and every nation is in a state of
anarchism toward Every Other Nation uh
if an American kills a Canadian Mexico
there's no higher Court to uh seek
Justice to you have to resolve it
between themselves well there there are
but those those Nations have established
uh courts and international bodies which
are mostly feckless like the UN or the
international criminal Corridor and but
but at least they have a
they at least have the structure of a
kind of legal institution sure point
being though again if an American kills
a Canadian in Mexico they're not going
to one of these institutions it's going
to be resolved between the three nations
somehow that's true that's true okay all
right I you you guessed mine incorrectly
so you have to drink your Pina I guessed
yours correctly so now you go okay okay
foreign
I disagree with the use of quotes here I
have the more fascist looking haircut
[Music]
you're going no I gotta move yours okay
okay
two three three
so I don't think it I think you got that
wrong I think I'm sorry to say
you do have the more fascist looking I
don't because if you look at the back it
comes to a point which is not what
fascists would have they would have it
very clean that's true that's true it is
it's got the fashiness of the it's
longer on top kind of shorter so you do
have that kind of extremely conservative
very primitive that is Hitler's haircut
it's just not as long yeah but on the
side part it's a little long I got some
sideburns I don't it's very hard for me
to grow the Charlie Chaplin you know I
can't quite do it but there's a band
named Sparks which have been around
since the late 60s his two brothers and
one of them had the German mustache for
decades and he never explained why and
this would drive people crazy and I
that's abandoned everyone should look up
because they're amazing Michael Jordan
has oh yeah for like a month McDonald's
commercial and everyone's like what are
you doing I did call Daily wire over
over the break between Christmas and New
Year's I just didn't shave and so by the
end I had this kind of scraggly ugly
beard and I I took a poll I said should
I show up with facial hair on Monday and
you know the PR department calls say
haha um did you are you sure are you
going to do that I said no no I'm not
I'm not going to do that
I'll shave it off I'm just going to keep
a mustache what is there a problem with
that I don't know what problem you see
with that okay
adults going to Disney World Without
kids should be illegal
this is I'm answering for you you gotta
answer how you think I would answer okay
one two three
I would definitely say no
[Music]
you know you'd say no I would have to
say yes I think you would not make it
illegal I would make it a capital
offensive no you would not I would it's
it's wrong it is wrong it's wrong I'm
not arguing that's not Disney so we all
agree in the objective kind of natural
law sort of perspective it is wrong for
these adults to show up and like get the
turkey leg and the in fact I had a
Twitter poll I said which is more of a
red flag and a female if she's a Harley
Quinn fan or she's a Disney fan because
those are both Big Run for the hills
yeah situation the Harley stuff she's
wearing it on her sleeve the Disney is
kind of the subtext there it's like this
is not going to end well for you with
her delusions of Princess Hood you're a
princess the white dressing like that it
doesn't it doesn't add up no no no I
listen I it's not that I I'm some kind
of authoritarian that is that's
literally that's not but I'm not a thing
Hitler mustache says I'm not an
authoritarian butt uh-huh but he's a
real liberal
he's at least a modernist you know yeah
no I the the problem is
certain offenses are serious enough I
think that they require State
intervention some of those would be
murder uh or you know serious sexual
crimes or
the the grown grown-up Millennials just
showing up you know and going on the
Dumbo ride
I assume I don't know I've never been to
but maybe it's just because I was never
taken to Disneyland you know we're gonna
get a video crew Michael and Michael do
Disneyland and it's good and we're just
gonna sit there being the whole time
but at least we'll have to wait in the
lines because we're important say Ben
can I at least get the fast pass no the
idea that you would get the fast pass is
frankly crazy okay uh this is obvious
I've got used to Delaware resources
you're like well that's that's not the
point okay my turn okay
[Laughter]
okay
the liver King taught us anything and he
hasn't it's that if you tell a lie long
enough eventually you will get the 2020
election results
okay ready one two three wait you put it
on your side of the board hold on yeah I
meant yes I can't reach you
um okay I'm a munchkin like you I'm
gonna say I'm gonna say
[Music]
um
no if you tell a lie this is so many
double negatives I don't even understand
but I do choose to drink okay
no you you uh have made the more
virtuous decision you don't drink I
don't drink because it makes me meaner
I'm not joking I realized this the other
day some people sometimes say accuses of
promoting booze on the show and I I
actually don't intend to promote booze
on the show I do drink socially uh so
now of all my devices it's never been
one that I'm really drawn to even to the
point that I'll have one drink at the
end of the night maybe over a cigar and
uh
but it was I think it was messing up my
sleep and I cut it out for like a week
and I slept much better I had more
energy even one one single drink at the
end of the night it took me years to
realize that my hangovers take the form
of being depressed because I'd feel
really down the next day even from one
beer and then I'd be like oh you know
those days where you're like what am I
doing like everything sucks and you're
like oh this is physiological yes it
took me a while to figure out that that
I didn't know hangovers could do that I
thought it'd just physically feel gross
I know no it actually it kind of rocked
my world because I really enjoy the
ritual of a drink at the end of the day
I don't even it's not like I'm doing keg
stands you know but I really like that
ritual but if I can't yeah it's that
same feeling and especially if I have
you know like three drinks or something
and then I have a headache the next day
ruins your whole day that's why I
recommend angel dust to all the kids at
Disneyland oh you want to go on the
Dumbo ride you don't have to wait in
line
it's just one puff away
life can be a circus with angel dust
so we've endorsed by Ben Shapiro
the yes or no game uh the white film by
Michael malice and angel dust yes
endorsed by Ben Shapiro yes yes okay and
of the Three Angels is clearly the best
product and I say this value of the
white pill why take a white pill and you
have white powder I could fly I can fly
Angel just needs to hire you to do its
PR I've never heard better PR uh number
three
SBF is more likely to face prison time
who's SPF he's the that uh Sam bangman
free the guy with the oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah SPF is more likely to
face prison time than Dr fauci
one two three
for sure he's probably not going to face
much prison time anyway but the
possibility of fauci facing prison time
to me is like these people who thought
Biden was going to put Hillary as the VP
and then step aside like it's these kind
of yeah there's one way Bernie can still
win there's still one weird trick Ron
Paul is going to get the nomination in
2012. it is so crazy because here's the
thing if they wanted to put fauci away
the dominoes it's not like you could
just put faster way and everyone goes
home like there's a lot of people that
led to that happening there's no
including Trump right there's no way
that happens there's what wow I don't
really think that's going to happen of
course not of course I mean there are
people Hope Springs Eternal and the
human breast but this guy has had a
record of of incompetence and Corruption
going back to the 80s going back to his
earliest years at the at the NIH and
they haven't gotten him for 40 years
right he's it's over when's the last
time they've gotten any bureaucrat for
malfeas reasons I don't think that even
Lois Lerner Lois Lerner deleted or lost
a bunch of emails and then it's like
well she did she did a good faith effort
no of course no the only ones I was
thinking maybe during Nixon but no those
were appointed guys they weren't
bureaucrats yeah they never get the
bureaucrats right it's the safest job
you can buy of course
quotes are incorrect on this
the white pill is basically just the
black pill for quitters
this this is like Mr Miyagi stuff excuse
me fired by French what is who writes
these riddles uh Buddha I think yes
Siddhartha Gautama actually okay ready
the the white pill is basically just the
black pill for quitters
one two three
I'm gonna no I'm gonna say the answer is
yes only in as much as the thing that
you're quitting is despair
that's a good thing to quit you're not
quitting it if you are renouncing it
that's not the same thing what's the
difference
you're a Catholic aren't you like a
renunciation is an act of uh repudiation
and an act of ownership and an act of
like I believe in this this is what I am
quitting to me has such a connotation of
giving up right you're saying it
quitting intrinsically has a kind of a
despair to it yes yeah but what if you
quit angel dust for instance then then
you'll just you go on vacation from
angel dust that's you don't ever Michael
why would you want to don't you want to
fly
kids I I'm telling you
like much better than watching this
garbage
I can't Michael I can't argue with this
yeah I can't I have no no okay fair
point I'm gonna keep this this card in
permittuity because it's not the best
things I've ever seen
okay the weird Satanic ritual stuff at
Bohemian Grove on Balenciaga shoots and
at the CERN A Large Hadron Collider is
far more about being an edgelord than
worshiping the
evil okay
one two three
yeah we're in agreement for sure they're
not trying to be Edge Lords they're
trying to be defiant and there's a lot
of genuine evil at these places and I
think they're you know the whole line
about the greatest trick the devil ever
did was give these people doesn't exist
these people get off on committing evil
in public and brazenly so right right
it's not just being an edge Lord is
you're harmless they're actually
harmless people they're actually Harmony
people and it can't be
you can't worship the devil ironically
forever you know or or really ever at
all like you can't people seem to think
there's like oh no tihihi no I'm going
to do these weird Satanic rituals and
commit all sorts of Acts of evil but
it's really it's actually ironic you
think well if you live your life
ironically then it's Earnest actually
but it's also at a certain point you're
not going to get enough of that buzz by
listening to Marilyn Manson right you're
going to actually want to start doing
things that actually impact other people
and and start doing harm or at least
being
um ignorant or like choosing not to do
good and like letting harm happen let me
hear something man there was I I don't
think I've told the story on air before
it's one of the most jarring stories
I've ever heard I'll give you the broad
scope because it's
horrifying there's a guy that I knew
freshman year I totally lost touch with
him in college but find out later the
guy gets arrested for very serious
crimes
leave it at that very very serious
crimes and uh
he reached out to me I hadn't talked to
this guy in years yeah I know we weren't
even that tight in college and uh so he
he said oh well he said can I can I call
you and explain what happened I said
okay sure whatever and so he calls me
and he says yeah first I got involved in
this first I got involved in some weird
sex stuff then I got involved in drugs
then I got involved in this kind of ring
and then I got involved with these older
people and then I got involved with
these rich guys and then before you knew
it we were doing Satanic rituals in
different countries and then
now I'm in prison I said you know the
part that people aren't going to
understand about that it's not the drug
stuff it's not the sex stuff it's not
the rich people stuff that's all kind of
part of this world right
the fact that
it always has the same kind of symbolism
to it for whatever reason it always goes
back to like some guy with horns and a
pitchfork and fire and it uh isn't there
something to the fact that all these
Elites are performing
actual overt Satanic rituals isn't that
kind of weird that they keep doing that
I don't know if weird's the word it's a
natural language well I am going to tie
this back to my book and because I think
it's Jermaine um one of the reasons I
wrote the white pill is and it's about
the rise of the Soviet Union in the fall
of the Soviet Union is because I was on
a conservative podcast they were talking
about how um Biden's a communist I'm
like do you even know what communism is
right and Americans are completely
oblivious to how evil people and
governments can be they think it's oh
you have to have woke ideology in school
and perhaps 70 uh interest rate no they
you have to your kids have to get up in
school and denounce you your kids are
taught in kindergarten to turn you in
even if your parents kill you because
the most moral thing you can do is to
report your parents if they're like
hoarding grain so they would encourage
priests to denounce God from the pulpit
in order to you know betray the people
in the in the congregation so you know
when people think about evil in this
country and they think go you know we're
two years away from buying destroying
America I'm like do you know what a
destroyed country they don't you don't
get you don't get how far this goes yeah
you're right yeah and as bad as you
think it is the basement has a seller
and when I found all these receipts
because even I didn't know half this
stuff uh the things that they feel
comfortable doing to families and to
kids is so much worse than because evil
often is creative that's the thing I
think people don't appreciate like even
people think of like the devil the
devil's smart imaginative right right
and you know if you and I sat down
and try to think of tortures the things
that they did it would never enter our
heads right right yeah this is the
uh Satanist wrote Into Me Once like an
open Satanist instead of Michael I want
to come on I'm not a big lib you know
I'm just a Satanist and I want to come
on and debate these things and I thought
I don't know if I want to platform an
actual Satanist and I wrote to a priest
friend of mine who's
very Urbane very uh
funny serious intellectual guy and gets
a kick out of all sorts of
eccentricities and so what do you think
about this he goes
watch out the devil's very crafty yeah
and don't I don't think this is just
some light he said I I wouldn't do that
yeah and I'd appreciate you not
repeating my communications with you
publicly and please yeah that's right
yes now I just kind of want to name some
of the priests I don't like like and
that breeze theme was yep okay well I'm
gonna drink anyway okay I think that's
the rule is it no I don't know sure
okay I'm often suspicious of people who
don't drink
hmm ready
orphan one
two three
I would say no no no I'm I'm often
suspicious people who don't like dogs or
don't like music yeah those are the two
where I'm like okay if unless they're on
the Spectrum something's really
dangerous here it's not that I don't
it's not that I dislike dogs
but I don't I'm not that into dogs okay
like people you know they're like they
love
chasing a dog like we found the Satanist
we found he's sitting at the table yes I
just think of myself as a people person
you know so some people say dogs are the
best people on Earth they are not
kidding they're definitely more pleasant
than men yeah how can you not be a dog
person all they want to do is be your
friend and help you do you know what the
re the reason I can't get that into dogs
is
they can never become reasonable like a
baby I can I can kind of get into
playing with a baby of women we're
talking about dogs
take away reason and accountability
yeah but hold on wait what was the
actual question about uh oh yeah no I I
am I am somewhat skeptical of people who
have never had a drink because
they were told that you know the drink
is just the devil and you know there's
well what if they have alcoholism in
their family they don't want to yeah
that I can understand that I can admire
and guys who Penn gillette's never had a
drink and now look at him really yeah
well that's the greatest argument for
drinking I ever heard no exactly no
people who have
kind of been through it you know have
experienced booze and said you know this
isn't for me far from being skeptical of
those people I sort of think oh this is
someone who gets it because you know the
flip side of it I mean there are guys I
know
who just never got over age 23. it just
and and
you know it doesn't going out to the
bars all night does not play as well
when you're in your 50s as when you're
in your 20s I interviewed Tucker Max in
my show he's he wrote the book I hope
they served dealer in Hell a class
Finish First and he's like I meet these
adults who were like dude I'm such a fan
of yours he's like yeah this is okay
when you're 23. what is wrong with you
I'm married with kids and I love it
that's what life's about like yeah I get
it like get drunk be a frappu you know
fool around but dude you're you're 30.
when I was into Tucker Max I was I was
17 I think yeah that was that was kind
of the audience wow that's great that's
he's a great guy he's in Austin as well
that's edifying to hear that he
yeah he wrote a book called Nate and
it's all about finding his wife's
awesome his kids are awesome wow
wow that's that's good there's happy
ending for him yeah yeah all right
between eating bugs living in pods
owning nothing and drinking from paper
straws getting people to eat bugs will
be the most difficult thing to get
people on board for the New World Order
between eating bugs living in pods
owning nothing and drinking from straws
one two three eating bugs is very easy
to get people to do so easy it's already
happening shrimp or bugs shrimp seem
like bugs lobsters cricket flour the
cricket flower stuff is already in chips
yeah it's fine it's not gonna be hard at
all they're not outside bugs and they're
fine
I try to bug once
I thought it was gross not the the
powder you can kind of just divorce from
your mind
the legs well yeah that's an antennae
that's the issue but you're not going to
serve them whole
yeah I hope not yeah you're right
they'll just grind them up they'll put
them in potato chips I am oh my God I'm
about to reveal a story I haven't told
anyone
I am so
um
uh such an animal person and I know a
lot about zoology there was a company
called either Cricket or grasshopper I
know this company called Cricket I think
it was cricket but I want to get it no
it was called Grasshopper And they were
launching like cell phones or something
yeah and they were having
chocolate-covered grasshoppers to
promote it
but they weren't grasshoppers they're
crickets and they're not the same thing
and I reached out to them and they try
to be like oh they are grasshoppers and
I went down that rabbit hole and go here
the difference is not the same animal
and I think they're out of business now
and there should belong in hell right
Lisa your entire identity also
grasshopper is according to the Bible
you're allowed to eat well some some
species some species okay do you want to
go full Ben Shapiro I went to Yeshiva
there are some species of grasshopper
that are Kosher yeah but they don't know
what those species are referring to in
contemporary times so for the sake of uh
of playing it safe you shouldn't eat any
that's actually the fact because I was
just asking a Orthodox Jewish friend of
mine this earlier today I said when you
know Clash fob makes us all eatsy bugs
uh surely we can the ones that the Jews
will be allowed to eat are locusts and
some some grasshoppers right
but he didn't know the answer that's the
answer we don't know which ones they
were because they'll say like the white
grasshopper we don't know what that
corresponds to right wow so to play it
safe yeah they don't don't go along with
the world economic Forum yeah no the
hardest the hardest one for people of
that list is going to be giving up all
their property no that's gonna be the
easiest you think yes because there's
lots of people already who basically if
you are have a government home
government food government car
technically the government owns
everything but provides things for you
they'll be fine with it but do even
these people who are on total government
assistance right they go out they buy
their TV or whatever they go they get
their phone it maybe they've bought it
with government coupons but they at
least think of that as being their own
possession even if even if the Repo Man
could show up tomorrow sure but they're
not they're not legal but in this
situation if the difference is they
don't legally own it what would they
care
you don't think if the repo guy showed
up they'd be very upset if these taken
out their TV they would but what
resource with recourse would they have
right right that's true I I just wonder
if the Obama phone no one's taking those
Obama phones right no no they're going
to keep giving those out but in the in
terms of the convincing people I agree
with you they could close Rob can
convince people to eat bugs it'll just
happen the pods is going to be hard the
pods I don't know people move to New
York City every year my first apartment
in New York my bedroom was was 70 square
feet it didn't it had three real walls
one fake wall and no windows but I think
people who are poor have a sense uh on
government housing do have some sense of
entitlement up to at least something to
get them to downgrade to a pod that's
going to be really really hard and the
wealthy people like people who talk
about global warming with their own
private jets they're not going to be in
a pod well they'll yeah the pods are not
for them yes the pot the pods and the
bugs it's only for the poor people yeah
that yeah but I just wonder if people
have a natural
inclination that that property is a good
thing
I don't think they do you don't think so
but to some extent like dogs do right
that's kind of what I heard yeah yeah
but again owning and there's the whole
the left-wing Anarchist version of this
uh private property and personal
property so technically the TVs the
government you know brand telephones
when like we were young weren't they the
government's probably right right yeah
yeah or of the utility yeah yeah that's
true that's true that's the future the
future is Dell Atlantic yeah yeah okay
well I'm gonna drink anyway let's do it
you're right if only this drink were
sweet as you no stop that get out of
here
you make me blush okay so this person
stole my look they dyed their hair they
put on the white suit I would at least
consider voting for Tulsi thick in 2024.
Tulsi thick you said yeah
from Hawaii
what okay
so would you not you would not consider
vote I don't believe in voting under any
circumstances
I wouldn't be inclined to you'd consider
it if she's against Biden you do it in
two seconds yeah
but I would even among Republicans I
might consider oh yeah if it was her
versus like Liz Cheney yes yeah that
would be hard I think she gets it more
than a Liz Cheney guess and even if you
look at their voting record and you say
well Liz Cheney on these specific issues
voted more conservative I just think
yeah but on all every time where her
vote mattered she sided with the libs
and and with Tulsi it's kind of the
opposite every time her vote was really
crucial her voice was really crucial she
kind of broke out of the Matrix a little
bit you don't you can't say that you are
a principled person and be against gay
marriage when you have a gay sister when
your dad who's an old man is for it and
then later be like oh oh no wait gay
marriage is great like you're a phony
yeah she's a fellow this this and she's
also fun fact was the model for Jim
Henson's Miss Piggy
yes
your word
okay I'm up
I have no idea what the score is and I
don't care no no one does no it does yes
this is the thing
being agnostic
is the non-committal version of the new
atheist movement
one two three
I would actually say
no okay I think there is no such thing
as the non-committal version of the new
atheist movement I think the new atheist
movement
Chris Hitchens Daniel Dennett Richard
Dawkins Sam Harris the whole point of it
was to just be so fanatically
flamboyantly atheist that to be
non-committal is is a separate category
of movement and so a lot of people are
I've been agnostic for a lot of my life
uh it's just I generally I find it to be
people who just haven't
thought about it I also I think it's a
no because it implies agnosticism came
about as a result of this movement where
it preceded it for a long time yeah of
course so and I don't I I don't think I
think agnostics are like moderates that
they just pick a lane yeah like it's a
lack of principle yes because it refers
to belief as opposed to knowledge right
so you could be an agnostic atheist or
agnostic theist hmm
even though even though agnostic
literally means without knowledge right
so it could be like I don't have
knowledge but I believe in God or I
don't have knowledge and I don't believe
in God but it's not a third choice wow I
you know I had not thought of it that
way that one one could be because I you
know I believe being a papist myself I
believe that the existence of God can be
known with certainty from the natural
world by the light of human reason and
it but many many people who are theistic
say well I can't really know I'm just
taking a leap of faith and so in a sense
they are agnostic
I had this personal intense religious
experience but I don't have knowledge
right down or have some deductions like
I just feel God in my heart wow that's
it so don't let these agnostics off the
hook there right no it's the worst
they're just unprincipled monsters you
know what will bring them closer to God
and that's angel dust
it has the word angel in it for a reason
ashes to ashes dust the dust it's
endorsed by the Bible I might have to go
to confession
when I think you know people sometimes
write into the show say Michael the
thing you said it really helped me I
proposed to my girlfriend right and you
know now in five years I'm gonna say
Michael my life was going great until I
watched you with malice and then I got
hooked I that they're watching you and
they're like I want to get married
yeah yeah until now until now it's a
wrap it's gonna be it's like I'm always
sunny it's like the guy and Always Sunny
it was like a good priest or the good
and then would we both be Dennis we
would I think I think we would both be
Dennis right it's like not even a
question
oh
I know I know my answer and I think I
know you answer I think this is easy
um abortion is worse than slavery
one two three yeah for sure I don't
think abortions worse than slavery how
not because I think there are cases when
abortion is acceptable
well and there's no case where slavery
is correct
okay there's a couple ways to approach
this but let's take it the first one
when do you think abortion would be
acceptable
um early on very early on also if
there's like some severe deformities
where the kid is not going to survive
those are cases when abortion is
acceptable why would you say I mean why
do you think that that would be
acceptable then let's say because those
are too distinct I'm sure I'm just
giving two cases where I would say those
things are far more acceptable than
slavery
but it wouldn't you wouldn't say it's
acceptable to kill
you you wouldn't say it's acceptable to
have an abortion in the first trimester
objectively you're just saying it would
be more acceptable than slavery no I'm
for I am pro-choice early on although
decreasingly so given uh uh it's it's
kind of very um disturbing to me as a
lifelong New Yorker to see how many of
these slippery slope arguments across
different issues have not only been
validated but like not only they put uh
butter and margarine on that slope they
also but I Can't Believe It's Not Butter
so it's just like that thing is so it's
greasedness because it's got seed oils
on it too yeah the Sea and the seed oil
poison yeah um but because my argument
my argument that that I think would be
acceptable within a kind of libertarian
or anarchistic framework for why
abortion is always worse than slavery is
that
abortion always ends a human life even
if it's a deformed person or even if
it's very early stage human life and
that the right to life is not merely one
right among many but it is it is the
fundamental right without which the
other rights cannot exist Kamala Harris
just had this this great quote the great
philosopher of our time Kamala she was
she was giving a speech at a
pro-abortion rally and she said you know
in our in our Declaration of
Independence we're promised we're
promised certain things we're promised
the right to
liberty and the pursuit of happiness I
kid you not yes you say wait what was
the that came before a liberty no no I
think it was before the yada yada the
good part yeah the the right too uh
liberty no what did you just call what
did I just hear and so you know you
can't pursue happiness without Liberty
and you can't have Liberty without you
don't pursue happiness without Liberty
you think so how can you pursue anything
without Liberty because there are people
who are in horrible places like I talk
about my book I've been to North Korea
you are pursuing happiness but oh when I
say Liberty I I mean it more in a in the
kind of Christian sense of the term
where you one can never take away the
liberty of one's mind oh yeah okay right
that is a priest precondition to
assuming happiness yes and so if if
slavery is a question of Liberty and
abortion is a question of life and
doesn't the question of life always have
to take precedence over the question of
Liberty yeah but I do think there are
certain cases we're taking first of all
I don't agree necessarily that early
abortion is a human life uh second of
all and that's all I know everyone yes
yes I know the comments thank you I'm
sure there's something ever heard before
but I I the fact that sometimes to me
acceptable whereas slavery is so beyond
the pale and I also love the idea I can
just hear the comments right now that
people even though that was the question
are going to tell me that me being
against slavery's virtue signaling
because you know that
I'm against it because he brought it up
I didn't bring it up spontaneously I
brought it up in response to the
question I like I like the idea that
it's not people aren't going to be upset
with you for being in support of
abortion in some cases is that you're
against slavery oh look at this that's
the internet for you I've got to get
heat for that wow okay all right well I
guess listen I guess I got that wrong I
mean I think I got the question right
but I I got your intuition wrong maybe
we slide down the slippery slope six to
12 more months maybe my answer will be
correct by then I am just gratified that
these different states that are enacting
pro-life laws are basically declaring
themselves anathema to awfuls uh
affluent white female liberals because
it's like this isn't your culture stay
where you belong and that to me is the
most important aspect of pro-life
movement that's true you know not most
important but a very important one but
it is it's funny you mentioned that
because the pro-life movement I mean
there were Democrats in the pro-life
movement they're they're leftists in the
pro-life sure and which I sometimes even
forget because I think it's all a
Conservative Christian Republican type
people but there is something I think
compelling as we see a political
realignment going on to just people
looking at me say well
the people on the pro-abortion side
they're just terrible they're just wrong
about everything I call myself
pro-choice really because first of all
if we're in its day and age where
pro-choice means nine months I'm out of
here yeah of course this is not an
argument like what are you talking about
you know Dave Rubin last I talked to him
on this issue he had he was pro-choice
he was totally fine with abortion and
I've noticed over the years
he he I say well so when do you think
it's acceptable and he keeps pushing
that date back you know and I I think
it's he's following that I think he's
following the logic of abortion as he
thinks about these things but I think a
lot of it also has to do with wait a
second so these people who are
ostensibly on my side of this question
they're wrong about everything else you
know that was that was actually
ugly and and
physionomy is never wrong but the other
thing is it's also different once you
have a kid that's so when there's a face
and it's like oh then it's complete you
know but Uncle now it's not the same as
being a dad obviously but it's just like
okay there's a similarity yeah there's
things there's like oh okay okay I had I
mean I I know
plenty of women who have had abortions
and some early some very late and I I
did have this thought because I you know
I have two
two kids one just turned two the other
one is six seven months old and I was
holding my little infant baby and I was
thinking especially a couple of months
ago I'm thinking
he doesn't look that different than he
did in the in the belly like that they
could it's like
this isn't you know they tell you the
pro-abortion people they tell you oh
it's you can't see the baby on a
microscope and it's all just a complete
lie I mean you can see these are like
real they got their little fingers by
like nine weeks or something very that's
true when you see seeing is believing I
guess in many cases
the Milo yay wet by the way I'm going to
put pause here do we have to say yay no
it's quite Kanye if I don't if I don't
call Bruce Caitlyn I'm not going to call
Kanye yet the um when I did Ben Shapiro
show a couple weeks ago for the first
time I ended it by saying that we ruined
Kanye's day which we did probably not
wait but who are
you that's sweet holder who is we though
uh the the Milo yay West and Nick
Fuentes visit to Mar-A-Lago was most
likely a Chloe CIA op designed to
destroy Trump's 2024 campaign before it
could even fully begin
one never two three
okay here's my issue with that meeting
yeah
if you're gonna meet the president how
according to Trump right he invited this
this uh
battled young man African-American man
that he's friends with and he brought
his friends and he
how do you get a plus two to meet the
president like I don't have a plus two
here and this is like as the bottom of
the barrel of content and you're going
to meet the president in his house after
the president had recently gotten in
crap for having classified documents
they're like we don't know who's coming
in and out and that's dangerous and he's
like oh no no we have security here
you're just letting a plus two like what
are you talking like and this is Trump's
argument but isn't that an argument that
it is a glowy no it's an argument that
he's sloppy yeah yeah I know that's kind
of more of what I think yeah I I sort of
think uh we're more glowy if they
planted the documents in Mar-A-Lago
right that would make more sense to me
if you want to do it's like okay here's
the nukes and here's the email where
he's forwarded to Kim Jong-un uh and
he's like hey buddy here's how you make
nukes for cheap and here's an
Angela yes yes I
I really like Trump and so I tend to
give him more of the benefit of the
doubt than a lot of conservatives do but
I think this is a clear-cut case of
Trump genuinely likes Kanye West they
actually have been friends for a while
they've Kanye was very supportive of
trump and Trump even you remember in the
Oval Office meeting
Kanye said I love this guy I've been
wearing the Maga hat all the time and
Trump actually said
yeah I know I just didn't want to put
you in a bad spot I didn't want to say
it oh wow yeah and so he I actually
think he had this care for this guy and
then it totally blew up the amount of
affection Trump has for celebrities is
so crazy Dr Oz after Walker like any
celebrity I I gave money to fetterman
because I want the Senate to be as much
like Arkham Asylum as possible yeah
um and thankfully that's happening I
wanted to run for president I I when
that race was happening and I said look
we
lost was for justice Mallet Oz was for
Trans transition children how are you
going to happen how is the Republican
party is there I was yelling at
conservatives on Twitter I go is there
anything someone with an R to their next
to their name can do where you like I'll
just take the loss on this one is there
anything it was uh when when Mr crudite
came out and I look I like a good crew
detail but when when he when he came out
and he was he's was attacking pro-lifers
on the radio not long before he started
running I didn't know what he did he
really yeah and and then he as a doctor
as a doctor of course you know he comes
out he's he's weak on the trans thing
he's just he's just a weekend didn't
campaign as hard as he should have and
and I whenever I would criticize him I'd
get this pushback of say well you don't
want Republicans to win and I thought
look if we're going to lose the Senate
anyway
and at a certain point you know the map
didn't didn't start to look right I
thought we're going to lose the Senate
anyway and we've got to have some lib in
the Senate I obviously want it to be
fetterman but that's way funny what is
the point of winning if you don't get
any of your issues through like how are
you winning like it's what cost the man
Victory if it cost him his soul like
okay I win and I have a Jesse Smollett
guy who's from Hollywood who's been
Oprah's you know lap dog for for years
what are you talking about yeah that's
not that's not a win I agree I agree
okay you're up okay
like this
I guess that gave away my answer
manifesting is astrology for straight
guys
do you do you manifest let's just give
your answer one two three
the answer is a no you manifest I
manifested this book no no Michael yes
no yes how did you manifest the book I
had the vision of what I wanted the book
to look like what I wanted to write yeah
I manifested this whole kind of book
roll out I mean no that's called having
a will and ability that's what
manifesting is no manifesting to my
understanding manifesting is
astrology for you know what does it says
go ahead so
I thought my understanding of
manifesting from my new age hippie
friends is that it is you know okay
you're a liar I look up any new age
happy friends
at least family okay there are there we
go there we go okay but these new age
hippie types
it's the idea that if you just think
something if you use your mind to
conceive of something that you can then
Force the created reality to bend to
your will and Imagination which is why
it's heretical I okay I think that
that's true and that can happen I'm not
joking no no no how does that happen I I
by exactly how you said it that said
what you're describing is not at all
analogous to astrology astrology is the
idea that you don't have that
manifesting power that basically you're
a subject to the whims of the Spheres
and all this other stuff so even if
these two things are ridiculous they're
not analogous well so they're what's
astrology for strika I think astrology
straight guys is this idea that happens
every 20 years that Western
civilizations at an end because
civilizations have this cycle yeah and
you know uh that Oswald Spangler kind of
stuff it's
that's astrology for straight guys
okay Michael I'm going to tell you
something
no it is you've just sort of
I was just
minutes before I came in here writing an
essay about the decline of the West and
specifically Oswald Spangler I write
about Oswald Spangler very infrequently
that is not a thing I often do but not a
fascist haircut but not any it's not him
in effect
yeah I don't know is Elvis a fashion
that's why it's Dean Martin if I don't
you home but I think what what just
happened I was about to say that you've
convinced me of manifesting because you
just brought up in a very obscure German
historian philosophy at the exact right
moment as we're discussing that but I I
would consider that to be and I have to
believe that that is uh closer to
Providence and and I think that's a Venn
diagram
but the difference is Providence is
God's will although what you're I guess
maybe then what you're saying is that
your will providentially happened to be
in a line you know there's that joke
about like God answers every prayer
sometimes the answer is no right yeah
but sometimes the answer is yes yeah
right right no that's true and I love
your point on astrology because
in in both cases manifesting and
astrology it is about manipulating
reality to achieve your but how is
astrology like that well because
astrology is just about reading the
predetermined fate of the world you're
not minute you're powerless you
manipulate nothing it says well your
only power is to is to uh understand it
okay right and then
and then I think the idea is to change
your behavior okay because this is
what's gonna yeah danger ahead so watch
out exactly whereas manifesting is
entirely about the will right
manifesting you're saying my will is
going to basically I will be God right
my will will transform the world I think
that you and I are I'm not saying this
sarcastically or cynically I think you
and I are both so blessed with the
careers and lives that we have that at a
certain point it just passes uh our very
very meager Talent our complete level oh
yes ma yeah yeah you know you know our
our devilish good looks but not quite at
the level of a Brad Pitt or something I
would say more demonic
gargoyle yeah
okay okay all right we're good
foreign
the war in Ukraine will last longer than
Biden's presidency
one two three
I think no really yeah I I assumed it
would last for 20 years no I think I
don't think the will is there from all
sides to go another six years
when do you think it ends sooner rather
than later honestly um I think the fact
that you have Republicans already
discussing where's this money going and
even at Kevin McCarthy's having a
backbone to be in any stance anti-war
that's true I think it's harder to put
it over to the American people I think
it's hard for Putin to be escalating
even more on the Russian side and I
think you know even though this was
regarded as oh my God you can't give
into aggression at a certain point
they're going to cut a deal and give him
some property or some land and then it's
like but can I I assumed that's how it
would wrap up I mean the the Doom and
Gloom prediction was oh uh Putin's Gonna
Roll in there he's going to take over
all of Ukraine it'll it'll last one week
and that's over and I didn't quite think
that would happen because Ukraine is
just a proxy for the West to what to to
fight this war with Russia so I said no
the U.S isn't going to give up Ukraine
that easy it's not going to go over in a
week but but now that zielinski has been
built up into Winston Churchill
can can he cut a deal
I think the corporate press would be
regarding him as heroic the man who
brought peace to Eastern Europe you can
write the Articles right now right right
he'll get the Nobel Peace Prize yes
certainly has he already gotten it or no
no no no I mean you could see them right
now they can they can do anything they
don't right right that's true that's
true in fact what they if it were in
their interest they would paint him as
Hitler right I mean they would right
instantly I mean Battalion has now taken
control of Ukraine all of a sudden yes
exactly they're going to be the news
again yeah yeah right okay right that's
good that's good
foreign
for once
um the midterms hyphenated uh the 2020
midterm election results in Florida were
more about the state's strict electoral
election Integrity laws than they were
about the better candidates
one two three
I think yes I think it was more about
the election Integrity laws you don't
think that DeSantis was a significantly
better candidate oh no he DeSantis is at
the moment probably the leading
Republican in the country he's been
right on almost everything right but I
and one of those things he's been right
on is election Integrity I
I suspect Arizona would have gone
differently
and even Pennsylvania might have gone
different questions about Florida right
so would Florida have gone differently
no no I don't think it would have gone
differently and it's not about the laws
exact wording here the 2020 midterm
election results in Florida we're more
about the state's strict election
Integrity laws than they were about the
better candidates so if the laws were
not there DeSantis would still have won
but less of a margin so it was about the
case he would have won he would have
it's about Florida it's about Florida
but it's not just about DeSantis it's
about the Congressional States it's
about the local seats this the
congressional seats I don't worry about
redistricting I don't think they're
about the laws but I'm not convinced
that the The Narrative that was spun was
that either DeSantis is just so popular
that he brought everybody along or that
the Floridians had their kind of wake up
moment no no it was about definitely
about the laws yeah
okay
all right let me reconsider them midterm
election results were more about the
states so do you think if Arizona
were not yet again at the center of a
controversy do you think we would have
had a
Governor Kerry like no really I think we
would I don't think like I'm not so sure
any first of all Biden took Arizona I
think Kerry lake is a lot I think she
was very sick every single article in in
Arizona was about was about carry Lake
was negative without exception many of
these articles even bother contacting
for comment sure I think the midterms
were far more blue than anyone was
anticipating yeah and I don't think she
had I think Hobbs won by a considerable
buffer I don't think this was a squeaker
I took a long time to count those
ballots but that sure and and the reason
for that is the reason for that is those
there were a lot of mail-ins and early
voting and Maricopa County had a lot of
weird things that happened in it notably
uh the machines break on on Election Day
and you had election officials
testifying after the fact and not crazy
sounding ones but normal ones testifying
to say look we had to check to make sure
that the provisional Ballot Box ballot
what do they call it box C or something
uh was empty by the end of the night but
no one checked to make sure that it was
empty at the top of the day and we ended
up and you hear these Precinct people
come in and say there were 200 extra
ballots over voters that checked in to
vote and so you think 200 exactly 202
and so you think okay that sounds a
little systematic to me and I'm no I'm
not alleging that Hugo Chavez you know
was was resurrected in in some voting
machine or something but especially when
you see Katie Hobbs Secretary of State
of Arizona was the one conducting the
elections and then even the Republican
quote unquote Republican election
officials in Maricopa County were a
validly anti-maga were I'm not I'm not
saying any of these people are decent
people being I'm looking at Georgia
right yeah the Georgia you have no uh
herscha Walker had two chances and he
blew them both whereas you had Camp come
through uh you know there is Federman as
we talked earlier is just like a walking
disaster so yeah I I think this kind of
uh I I think they just work the system
better than the Republicans did yeah
yeah I think I think there's outside of
Arizona when we're talking about
maybe Pennsylvania certainly Georgia I
think that's true and and there is no
question and Gretchen Whitmer and
Governor I mean the fact that I don't
think conservatives have a good
explanation as to why either of these
people hulkel or Whitmer had even 10 the
roads right because there's a lot of
people who will just vote blue no matter
who there's also this fact of Ron
DeSantis
who he's getting Flack now because he
necessarily is in the anti-trump lane
because Trump is running but if Trump
weren't running he'd be in the Trump
Lane of the of the presidential race and
and so he's he's getting Flack also
because anti-trumpers are supporting him
because he's the anti-trump so you know
that's not his doing that's that's a
fact of the circumstance it is it is
simply the case that Ron DeSantis is
leading the charge so for instance at
the other day he comes out and he says
we're going to ban Chinese investment in
real estate and we're not going to only
ban investment from the CCP because the
CCP doesn't only buy rooms of course
right they're not going to say okay sign
your name CCP there we go right and and
so he it's a it's a pretty broad band
and then what happens two weeks later
Christina in South Dakota followed a
suit so he he is in many cases setting
the agenda yes so I'm not I'm not
downplaying that but also I wish other
states would follow Governor desantis's
uh pace and uh fix their freaking voting
laws well I wish that Governor Abbott
stand up for something in his life okay
come on did you just see his tweet over
the weekend he says he's a better Kicker
than the the Cowboys guy so if he makes
the joke I can make the joke I am
delighted as a Texan that it is now the
official policy of the Texas Republican
party to have a referendum on Texas
secession and I think that is something
that is actually going to happen sooner
rather than later are you protects it I
am beyond protects it or do you do you
worry about like
partition in India was not peaceful or
the breakup of Yugoslavia was not
totally we spent two years being
everyone in this country was imprisoned
in their home we are not living in
peaceful times we're just living in
docile times
well that was pretty good
good night everybody okay am I up I
think so yeah
let's see
all right this
the clintons have a higher body count
than your average okay come on who
writes these
the clintons have a higher body count
than your average Arizona State
University's Sorority Girl roughly 187
due to YouTube rules make your guess but
do not verbally confirm if the other
person guessed correctly give only an
ambiguous non-verbal confirmation what
this is what okay okay
yeah
um the Clinton so you can't touch the
drinks you can't say
the clintons have a higher body count
than your average ASU Sorority Girl
roughly 187.
I I this is I I don't like this question
um
I okay I'm okay we're gonna count to
three right one two three yeah that's a
very high number
for the girls or for the clintons yes
and at that point you're just gonna need
some kind of like balm
good Lord
yeah
don't know no vertical confirmations
though
okay
there there's a backstory here
why am I here I should be I asked myself
in the Republic of Texas I know all
right
the term is co-authoring because the my
name is on the covers
ghost writing
for a black man is basically blackface
in print form
foreign
okay so I co-authored God what dialect
did you write in theirs so I co-authored
two books of DL Hughley
blackface is a caricature when you're
co-authoring a book you're doing it true
to the person's voice as much as
possible you're not trying to put on
this ridiculous Over the Top If I prefer
if I today there was actually gonna say
one more thing the French word for Ghost
Writer is black writer really yes
I I prefer to say writer of color
actually I do if I there is a five
letters are right
technically there there was a there was
this bit that said that I I was cast in
a new daily wire movie to play Malcolm X
that they were going to reboot the
autobiography now if I came out
and I I said you know well that's just
the chickens coming home to roost you
know and I I came out and I but notice
I'm not this is not some I'm not doing a
soft shoe or anything I'm just I'm just
saying a line that's the chickens coming
home to roost when President Kennedy
gets killed and let's say that I my face
were covered in
in black makeup
would that still be blackface even
though I'm not it's just not a
caricature this is not I'm not so it's
recent years has become identified as
blackface which it's not but it's not
okay that's fair enough um I I can get
into the whole history of blackface and
I'm not going I think you know by the
way I remember I was sitting with an
Uber driver and there was some blackface
non-traversing was going on and I said
he was clearly a conservative guy black
guy and and how is he clearly
conservative he was he was driving a
Cadillac I think he had like a flag
sticker I mean he was not hiding yeah
yeah and and but he system he goes oh
blackface man I don't care about that if
people are just having fun you know if
you're trying to be cruel or something
that's not good but if you're just
having fun I don't think it's no big
deal and I thought you know if you write
out blackface entirely if you write up
people playing caricatures characters of
other races or writing even in that
style you're writing out a lot of the
American Theater
you're writing out the jazz singer one
of the greatest movies ever made you're
writing out remember when they they got
rid of um Aunt Jemima
as I said Andrew mime is a black
caricature Candace got her off the
plantation where our kids at the time
Candace wanted to sell her own pancake
syrup which would have been incredible
and I was strongly supportive of that
but the answer why my character was
played by a black woman and written by a
black comedian named Billy cursands who
was a a black performer of minstrel
theater so now we're writing that guy
out we're writing the actress who played
Angeline we're just writing all of that
out so I have a Minstrel show joke in
this book I downloaded a book of
minstrels this book has everything it
does I know it's so great so here's a
Minstrel show joke
this is as written from early 1900s by
YouTube Hey
what's the difference between the
morning dew
and the late President McKinley this is
the only by the way this is the only
President McKinley joke Willie McKinley
one is missed from the heavens and one
is missed from the earth wow it would be
funnier if I had you know that would
make it much funnier than it was yeah
I'm gonna have to use that one yeah go
far sometimes I give these college
speeches and I was trying to open up
with a little Icebreaker he was like Hey
what's the thing about McKinley I
don't know something about the Earth
anyway let's talk about taxes I actually
did a little bit of blackface on
Reuben's show and he edited it out
because how did you do it I'll tell you
right now he
said he calls me the Willy Wonka I've
never told anyone this story I'm glad I
get to tell it so he calls me the Willy
Wonka of politics and I said to him well
Dave you know Willie I'll do the whole
bit is really I planned this whole thing
out I said well the thing with Willy
Wonka is you know he punished people for
their sins Augustus Gloop greed uh
gluttony Baruch assault greed Dave Rubin
sodomy
but you still get chocolate all the same
and I reached into my pocket and I had a
bag of pudding in a plastic bag and I go
oh it's all melted oh God and I got he's
like you got some on your face like oh
here and I just put it putting all over
my face and I go and then I said I think
I just became the prime minister of
Canada
and then he turns this producers he goes
what do we do
and we had to wipe my face off and it
never aired
someone get me pudding I wanna I want
this bit live that wow yeah there you go
I I'm gonna have to go through the
Reuben archives to unearth that
yeah yeah ghost riding series it's me
okay it was Ghost running that drink
thank you if each pill red blue black
and white yeah or actual drugs
the red pill got to chop them up
kind of like a certain
the red pill would be alcohol the blue
pill would be estrogen
the black pill would be Xanax
and the white pill would be shrooms
because everything's going to work out
man that's not what the white white pill
in this book does not mean everything's
going to work hold on we got to answer
first well no but the premise is wrong
because does it say everything's gonna
work out man or you said that no that's
what it says the white pill means hope
it's not guarantee a victory it just
means there's an opportunity for it so
your answer I'm gonna guess it's no
there's no yes of course and my answer
is no yeah this is what shrooms are the
Red Pill by the way they're not they're
not whatever one they said right because
the the red pill is just about kind of
shaking up your perception of the way
that things really and the understanding
that what you've been told your entire
life is a consciously constructed lie
not mistakes yeah yeah right but the but
people misunderstand this because they
think they think something like the
white pill or just having hope they
think that that's just a an arbitrary
and an unfounded Choice like optimism
are you a pessimist or an optimist
Pollyanna Paul yes exactly and I think
optimism and pessimism are two sides of
the same coin they're they're just
emotions that you choose to try to yeah
yes whereas hope is a in my view a
theological fact and but it it is a fact
of the world based on my understanding
of how the how the history of the world
has unfolded and it is uh is a far
deeper thing than just uh well I hope it
all works out that's why I wrote the
book because people like why are you so
hopeful about America look at this look
at that look at that and it's like 75
this book is really dark so I'm not
praying the white pill isn't nothing bad
ever happens the good guys always win
there's no setbacks I go through what
the Soviets did to their own citizenry
and it is so absolutely horrific that's
another thing I love when people
criticize Miss anarchists like oh you
think people are basically good I'm like
I'm from the Soviet Union I did the
North Korea book no I do not think this
but the point being they still lost and
they didn't lose voluntarily they didn't
lose because they became good people
they didn't lose because they're like
what are we doing this is wrong they
lost because of certain structural
choices and decisions that people made
that force them to kind of surrender
their terms so I am hopeful not because
of some naive view of human nature I am
hopeful because you can't look at the
enemy class and think these people are
unstoppable they're not particularly
impressive right right we have this idea
of the omnipotent Libs or whatever the
omnipotent political observation or
political uh opponent rather and I just
think
how impressive are they yeah they have a
decent amount of power right and
momentum yeah I don't mean to downplay
that but
I don't know they're not like the be-all
and end-all right I mean they still have
to they're still fighting us they're
still trying very hard to clamp us down
why because they're not up this country
was won by a bunch of white trash who
didn't even have shoes against the
greatest Empire in the world it's not a
nice way to talk about Thomas Paine but
yeah and and and the greatest army in
the world and an Empire and a king and
they were hungry and cold and they
constantly had to retreat and they won
yeah um we are Americans Victory Is Our
Heritage so to claim that we can't
defeat the enemy class today the the
universities look at these professors
you're gonna see the table to them are
you nuts yeah Kamala Harris she's what
finally ended America that's it she beat
us how could we possibly beat Kamala
Harris crazy I know okay I got the last
one you got the last one
I don't even know who this first person
is this is how old I am
I don't even know who
between Mariano Rivera who's that oh the
yank great Yankees closing pitcher oh
okay Ariana oh Donald Trump okay and
Pete Davidson
there's a um
there's my favorite comedian someone
named Neil hamburger and he's a great
comedian I think he's my favorite name
you know and he has this great joke
about
um in the in the comedy tour of Carrot
Top Dimitri Martin and Aziz Ansari who
was most deserving of a standing ovation
why the pilot who flew their plane into
the side of a building
um side of a mountain excuse me I so
between Mariano Rivera and then if then
when people don't laugh he goes come on
guys I have cancer yeah
um or would that be funny if there's a
black choir behind me okay between
Mariano Rivera Donald Trump and Pete
Davidson skeet is that who's which is is
uh Kanye's nickname for Pete okay is
hands down the greatest closer of Our
Generation so okay I get this one one
two three
I no he's not Pete Davidson's the
greatest closer yeah he lands all these
chicks yeah and he's he's not
I don't want to disparage people but
the women are much more attractive than
he is yeah but I don't think he's the
greatest closer like
oh of the three oh then yes then yes for
sure yes because I would say yes no
that's not a question I would still have
to give it to Mariano I think being a
you know a New Yorker a Yankee fan is
the only sport oh so I got it right so
you got it right yeah but you know what
I'm gonna drink anyway okay good finish
that thing chin chin cheers Michael
a true pleasure this has been a lot of
everyone and
you need to write another book more
quickly so that you can come back or we
can like twist your arm to come back
without a book
where can we go
whitefillbook.com and in all seriousness
the reason I wrote this book partly is
because conservatism at its best
it's about studying the lessons of
history and applying to today right but
it is shocking to me how few
conservatives know the story of the
Soviet Union and the part that Reagan
and Thatcher played in liberating half
the world basically peacefully and this
is something that the New York Times
can't be expected to tell you and own
your Victory like this you guys did this
so this is part of that story that's
great I I can't wait to read this is I
this is my copy copy okay so I get I now
have my copy of this book you can get
your copy of uh the yes or no game uh
also at the daily wire shop and you can
get PCP in any dodgy neighborhood in
your city go get that uh or they'll
deliver it to your house or they'll
deliver it to you I'll give you the guy
yeah
okay can we Mr Davies can we cut that
out of the final show I hope I'm Michael
Knowles this is the yes or no game we'll
see you next time
[Music]